1945 World War two had concluded
victoriously America's only five star
Air Force general looks to the future
and the role of airpower
there will no longer be any spot on
earth and certainly not in America that
is saved from attacked by air for our
protection
we must have an Air Force second-to-none
for this we need a great aviation
industry a great air transport system
and a great body of trained personnel we
need more than planes pilots mechanics
women scientists and mathematicians and
we'll need to pour inventive genius of
the American people with these we can
protect the future ourselves and our
allies with the weapons of the beauties
general HAP Arnold together with other
pioneers in military aviation and
leaders in world war ii envision the key
element in the future would be an
institution dedicated to training
leaders in military aviation their
dreams came to fruition in April 1954
when President Eisenhower signed
legislation to establish the United
States Air Force Academy in June that
same year this site near Colorado
Springs was selected as its permanent
home while architectural planning and
construction would be formidable and
time-consuming the fledgling Academy
wasted no time in its morning
a dream comes true for the United States
Air Force at Lowry Air Force Base
Colorado 306 cadets of the first class
marched to ceremonies dedicating the Air
Force Academy for General Hubert Harbin
Academy superintendent secretary Talbot
General twining
and other Air Force leaders like them
the dream of a separate Academy goes
back over 30 years color guards from
West Point and Annapolis Duluth the
occasion the Academy will Crane cadet
specifically for air operations at first
commissioned officers will act the role
of upperclassmen before studies begin
freshmen cadets receive nine weeks of
basic training
a suggestion of the Ariel night which
the cadet will come daily
general Hartmann introduces airport
secretary Harold eat helmet here are
portions of the Secretary's address we
were here to found a great national
institution one that is dedicated to the
United States therefore the burden of an
individual airman has become much
greater than ever before you a cadet
here today face a challenge given the
few young men that is preparing
yourselves to lead the most powerful war
machine on the face of the pole again
one which is dedicated solely to the
prevention of war meanwhile at the
permanent site work proceeded at a fever
pace and at a press conference revealing
the grand plan for the complex academy
superintendent harmony charted the
institution's Court might call the basic
missions of the Air Force Academy that
is to say to motivate the youngsters
that we get through four years of
indoctrination and the development of
the pre decor to motivate them to a
lifetime of service to their country in
the airforce a second is to provide of
course a continuing dependable flow of
officers of that dedicated type into the
Air Force a third is that we aim to
establish curriculum planning are
directed for the presentation of these
youngsters an academic curriculum
tailor-made to what we conceive to be
the ultimate requirements of officers of
the Air Force and finally it is our
responsibility to develop in them those
higher standards of loyalty integrity
and patriotism which constitutes the
silicone arm in any first-class military
establishment and so faithful to the
first superintendents charge the Academy
stands today and air officer commanding
of a cadet squadron of the first class
is the current superintendent Lieutenant
General Kenneth Tallman there has been a
great deal of growth in this first
quarter century of the Air Force
Academy's existence and of course I'm
not just talking about growth of the
physical planet
I know how much general Hartmann
contributed to the early planning in the
early thinking on what the Academy was
all about what I'd hoped to achieve when
you look at the threefold mission is
stated by General Harmon and reiterated
by every superintendent since that time
including myself you naturally try to
relate that to the needs of the country
prior to World War two of course the
role of the airplane in war was not very
well defined with with the technological
advances that came out of World War two
in the early post-war years it became
apparent that we had to add that some
kind of program which was either going
to convert army officers to Air Force
officers or we were going to produce our
own the new Academy produced its first
officers in 1959 and four years later
when President Kennedy was the
commencement speaker Academy graduates
were holding important positions in our
nation's defense forces you'll hear
today on this field your colleagues over
on the path or maybe stationed in
Western Europe or men who are a.cian
shift the hundreds of miles of land or
soldiers in camp in Texas or in the
island of Okinawa they maintain the
freedom by being on the red beanies
distant ship these distant planes these
distant men keep the peace in a great
posture stretching all the way from
Berlin to South Korea recognizing that
in the most difficult time in the whole
life of freedom the United States is
called upon to play its greatest role
this is a role which we are proud to
accept and I'm particularly proud to see
the United States accepted and the
presence of these young men who have
committed themselves to the service our
country under the cause of its freedom I
congratulate you all
and most of all I congratulate your
mothers and fathers made it fun moments
of inspiration that's live with a cadet
throughout his career the faculty at the
Air Force Academy has been predominantly
military not only of these instructors
provided a role model for the cadets but
they've also brought a diversity of
academic backgrounds from many civilian
university for a number of years the
Academy has enjoyed a distinguished
visiting professor program which has
produced extremely positive results for
both faculty and cadets the excellent
necessary to succeed at the Academy is
seen in later years many of the
challenging assignments at the nerve
center of all Air Force operations and
activities good lay holding the post of
assistant for general officer affairs at
Air Force Headquarters
Colonel Robert oak class of 59 a long
way from the foothills of the Rockies to
the banks of the Potomac lots happened
to me and through all the class at 59
over those 20 years since graduation we
walked on Lowry Air Force Base that day
feeling like each one of us knew what
was important in life
to go off and play ball or get an
education or learn to fly or whatever
and those were the things that the Air
Force Academy were about on that July
day they were about making his sweat and
making a run and making you miserable so
here to appreciate how lucky had been a
couple of weeks earlier never ceases to
be amazing how much just getting a real
close haircut changes the guys outlook
on himself and on those around him I
didn't believe they would design a
uniform to demean but sure enough they
said get in that little baby blue beauty
and March out there it was interesting
to look back on our eagerness with which
we look forward to going down to the
permanent site down at Colorado
that was what the Academy was all about
well June wheat was a superb time of
enjoyment retrospect on what wonders you
wrought with your life in those past few
years and and also an important part was
enjoying the families I remember this
very clearly how much I appreciated the
opportunity to meet with the families of
the friends that I've made over four
years and we really were a very
close-knit group I'm very thankful that
that close-knit aspect is endured over
the years over those years Academy
graduates have assumed the leadership
role in line combat organization along
the world it's much 1979 hey I saw your
Air Force based in Michigan temperature
seven below zero with a wind chill
factor somewhere around 20 below
messieurs secretary better another class
of 59 member Colonel Robert Becker
commander of the 4/10 bombardment way
I'll be 52 out there Colonel buckle wing
commander Airmen Hall reports 8 Bravo
all secure Thank You airman Hall routine
discipline by the numbers something that
is the must in our strategic forces
something a my dad that became a way of
life at the Air Force Academy by
day-to-day activities and what was
expected of us after death
it's an interesting concept I think that
you picked up while you're at the
academy from the standpoint that you
must learn to do things in accordance
with rules and regulations individually
and their course has great application
as far as your responsibilities with the
type of weaponry that our air crews do
carry on their aircraft we can make no
errors with those type of weapons none
can be a weak link in the chain or else
the mission will fail so each has an
individual responsibility but have a
broader responsibility to the team and
they sense it and feel it and operate
that way we did that the academy and
flights or your squadrons or not
enthusiasm
since its founding in 1954 the only
crucible of conflict to test the Academy
man was Vietnam and he was not found
wanting
the air war produced several laces
Academy graduates were among them one is
Maj Jeff Feinstein class of 1968
exception flying fighters requires
aggressiveness imagination and the
ability to act independently
aggressiveness in particular is one of
those attributes they try to teach at
the academy during the Vietnam War I was
in the 13th tech fighter squad and on
the 13th of October 1972 I got my fifth
kill a mig-21 over North Vietnam I came
out of the radar and I got the first
visual where we call Tally Ho it was the
big was 12 o'clock high one mile we
turned hard into him got another radar
lock on and shot two missiles at him and
the first missile got the kill second
witness
you'll need the second woman personal
with during the Vietnam conflict some
150 Academy graduates gave their lives
or remain missing
the legendary member of that group was
lieutenant Carl W Richter who flew 198
missions in Southeast Asia before giving
up his life in the service of his
country the dedication to duty of those
graduates who participated in the
Vietnam conflict reflects the high
professional standards which an
important part the Academy experience 31
for prisoners of war among them
captain Lance P Saiga won the Medal of
Honor posthumously while resisting the
enemy while in captivity brain 1973
analyzed American prisoners of war are
released from North Vietnamese prison
of those who returned from captivity one
after more than six years of EOW the
Academy's executive for professional
ethics Lieutenant Colonel John fer I
think the major asset that I gained in
my four years the Air Force Academy was
sense of self discipline the Reisner
trophy our newest acquisition at the Air
Force Academy exemplifies the high moral
standards and high sense of integrity
which the Air Force Academy tries to
teach to cadets
this goes a long way in helping to
develop the firm foundation of public
confidence which is so necessary in the
Air Force
today in a pure W environment is
extremely important that one have a
strong sense of self-discipline to
resist a lot of the pressures both
psychological and physical pressures I
think that most PLW developed their high
annual record of resistance to the
Vietnamese simply by calling upon their
own personal experiences the ability to
adapt to the situation and setting their
mind to it and those are very qualities
that are developed right here at the Air
Force Academy excellence is the
watchword for the Academy's military
training and leadership development
program and it's attained by surmounting
repeated physical and mental challenges
over the past 25 years there have been
many subtle changes in the methods of
teaching leadership which are more
mature which is provided cadet with a
relevant environment in which to
practice their skills before going out
into the Air Force as officers a class
of 59 member in an important leadership
position is the first graduate to earn a
general star
he's Harold Pete Taj now executive
assistant to the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff throughout my own Air
Force experience I found that the
background of training at the academy
and leadership was most valuable in the
context of
learning to get along with people and
living in a four-year leadership
laboratory that allowed me to learn the
experience of both leading people and
even most important perhaps learning to
follow I think most people have a
certain set of skills and capabilities
which can be focused and this is what
the Air Force Academy does the Air Force
Academy
although service academies for that
matter do provide the basis but it goes
beyond what you learn in a classroom or
even environment at this what a man or
woman has inside himself and a degree to
which he's willing to sacrifice and
subordinate his own self-interest for
for a greater good I'm not naive enough
to think that everyone doesn't have some
degree of self interest that's human
nature but it's the degree to which that
is subordinated in in the professional
values that are part of our service that
I think it is the military ideal I think
the Academy does a marvelous job to
bring that out
the physical education and
intercollegiate sports program prepare
cadets for a demanding life and give
them the self-confidence and physical
stamina necessary for effective
leadership many cadets have gained
national recognition a wide variety of
sports the Academy's first football
all-american was from the class of 59 is
Lieutenant Colonel Brock Strom now an
engineer with the space and missile
systems organization the last five years
I've been the director of engineering on
a Navstar global positioning system it's
been a team effort now that the system
is up and operating and it works it
reminds me of the effort that was took
to play in the Cotton Bowl in 1959 that
year we played something like seven Bowl
teams in the process of going undefeated
and we had a very very good football
team and culminated the season with a
tie in the Congo well I think the
Academy tries to get the type of person
who is very interested in athletes and
is willing to take on and rises to the
competition that is available in sport
and I think that comes out in the
intramural program and I have a son
who's there at the academy right now and
his feedback from the action in the wing
is that the competition is just as keen
now as I remember it
the airport Academy and the cadet wing
have undergone a number of important
changes during the past 25 years in 1964
Congress nearly doubled the authorized
cadet strength the current level of
about 4,500 this led to a new field
house in dormitories additions were made
to the academic building gymnasium
hospital and the cadet dining hall
Falcon stadium which was built entirely
from contributions collected by the
Academy Foundation was completed in 1962
the cadet Chapel the architectural high
point of the Academy was completed and
dedicated in 1963 perhaps the most
dramatic change to occur at the academy
has been the entry of women into the
cadet wing in the summer of 1976 women
than men participate in the common
training program designed to prepare
them for common duty assignments after
graduation from the beginning Academy
cadets have excelled academically the
first quarter of a century they had 120
growth scholarships numerous Guggenheim
fellowships various other study awards
typical of winners of graduate academic
Awards is 1979 Rhodes Scholar to that
Jeffery Jackson the Academy provides an
excellent background in education and
experience for a wide variety of careers
in today's Air Force the Air Force is a
very technical oriented service and they
need engineers and scientists to
continue their mission and the major
emphasis here at the Academy is on
engineering courses and everyone is
required even though political science
majors are required to take aeronautical
engineering and dynamics something to
give them a basic understanding of
Science and Engineering in the same
light the electrical engineer is
required to take human values course in
English literature and history courses
on the American Way of war
the balanced humanities and engineering
curriculum with academies provides the
Graduate with all that he needs for any
job in the Air Force a man who has
successfully put together a balance of
science and the humanities his 1964
graduate major Fred Gregory currently a
NASA astronaut this is the National Air
and Space Museum inside will see the
history of man and atmospheric flight
and Space Flight I'm a member of the
shuttle program and I certainly hope to
be a part of this museum soon and it all
began at the Air Force Academy
I think just about everything at the
academy aim you towards space when I
entered the Academy I had a I had upon
hope of becoming a member of the space
team but it was a it was a far-off dream
it's like dreaming to be the president
Italy it's a goal but you never expected
to achieve it however when I selected my
courses to take I tried to take courses
that would broaden me the Aeronautics
courses the astronomy courses the
mechanical engineering courses the
physics courses of course all were the
faces and background for the work that
I'm doing now the English courses the
technical writing courses the speaking
courses all contributed and to my
success and I suppose that everybody
success we have in the program with the
three other Academy grad so I think we
were well represented for a total of 55
or 60 astronauts four Academy graduates
is a pretty good average 25 years ago
90% of the entering cadets had to
qualify for pilot training today that
requirement has been reduced to 60% one
of those who entered the Academy knowing
he would not be a pilot his 1976
graduate lieutenant Mickey Duvall five
minutes the panels that go on at that
time and he got to be information after
that
not every Academy graduate becomes an
air crew member many of us join the
support field for example myself I
joined and become a member of the
aircraft maintenance team as a cadet I
was able to participate in many of the
airmanship programs some of which were
the orientation flights also a third
lieutenant program and finally I'm most
proud of my parachuting that I
accomplished at the academy over the
years the Academy's airmanship program
has used many ways to open the door to
the world of flying in the stale plane
the student experiences the basic
principles of aerodynamics 50:43 exposes
the cadet to the sophistication modern
navigation equipment and techniques
those who are qualified for pilot
training taste the power flight in the
t41 lieutenant the raw sums up the
experience
I think that the programs are they
participating as a cadet has helped me
immensely and understanding what the
aircrew members are going through on the
flight line it's helped me to appreciate
their role as a air crew member got them
gone backlund class of 71 received the
Air Force Cross for his actions during
the mayagüez incident I've been very
fortunate my Air Force career to get an
opportunity to fly several different
types of aircraft
I began by flying rescue helicopters and
then transition into fixed-wing jets the
academy influenced me tremendously I
read something as the cadet in a book
that has that struck me as a cadet
that's a very young man and I remembered
ever since it's a quote by Winston
Churchill he and I'm paraphrasing
because I don't remember the word for
word but he said there comes a time in
every man's life and he is called upon
to do something very special something
for which he and he only has the
capabilities and the skills and instant
the necessary training
what a pity if the moment finds the man
unprepared and in my mind that's the
mission of the United States Air Force
Academy ensure that every cadet requires
the preparation develop the skills and
the training and the attitudes so that
when the moment finds him in his career
United States Air Force will be prepared
captain Don Backlund lost his life in an
aircraft accident in August 1979 well
this film was still in production